could larger traditional defense primes
just acquire startups this is a good
question to harness their tech in human
capital much like other big tech
companies such as Google do with
startups though all these advantages
larger scale companies have when I when
I started PayPal years ago a very
different context there was always asked
why can't a big bank just do this and
I'd never had a good answer to that
because in theories the banks have
scaled they can have longer time
horizons they have more capital they've
a lot of talent and I think I think the
general answer is that it's just the
internal politics are unbelievably bad
and this and this is true not just a you
know large parts of the government it's
also true of a lot of large corporations
become incredibly politicized in ways
that are not good for innovation so I
think you can acquire a technology
company at that point where you don't
need to innovate anymore so so so if
it's a if it's a fully formed thing
maybe that's that's the point at which
you it makes sense for the primes to
acquire them but if you still need to
maintain that culture of innovation
that's gonna be very hard to do